a piano concert in the forest may not be
for every classical music fan but
Hachiya beautifully says she likes to be
unconventional
I like to make connection with different
things to communicate different arts
like for example theater and music
literature and music or nature and music
you know I like to make things together
synthesis it makes something more
inspiring for me and more interesting
earlier in the day there was a little
rain but fortunately for Katia it's
eased off
the air is still moist and full of
mosquitoes but the 26 year old didn't
let them put her off
they're quite aggressive but nice
because sometimes they were listening
they were quite sometimes they were
really a question we depended on the
pace it's a joke as Katya prepares for
the show her older sister Vanessa
applies some insect repellent they grew
up in the Georgian capital Tbilisi both
were taught to play the piano by their
mother and Katia went on to become a
star at 10 years of age she was already
touring the world the sisters have
remained very close they lived together
in Paris and give unser companies Katya
almost always on tour they even play the
piano together
it's great because we are completely
different personalities we have quite
different character but we have more or
less same taste and it's like plus and
minus you know we just understand each
other with our different characters we
still understand each other and it makes
ours I think it makes our playing more
intense and comprehensible also because
we understand each other
so it's harmonic and at the same time
intense I like it it's fun and it's
pleasure so far hutch has released two
albums and has had a great deal of
success
in 2012 she received Germany's echo
award for her debut album which featured
the works of Franz Liszt
the concert in the woods is part of a
film being made about her the ambition
over dinner she said she loves to be in
the woods in nature and that she feels
really connected with my homeland and
nature and so on so we thought what
could we do we then came up with the
idea of going into the woods near Berlin
in doing a little open-air concert for
her kin we'd invited on Bachman
California 50
it was a complex undertaking the sound
equipment and a valuable and fragile
grand piano had to be set up in the
forest at abou Nitesh Philly played
selections from her new CD due out in
2014 I wanted something more personal
and I chose a theme which is my mother
this is dedicated to my mother they CD
and it shows both personal lives my
mother's and mine because it's related
it starts from her and continues in me
Katya beautifully among the trees and
out of the hall venue for a pianist who
occasionally likes to strike an odd note